المحاولات الروسيه مستمره لوقف اي تقدم من
قبل قواتيف في عمليتها العسكريه باوكرانيا
حتى وان استلزم الامر نشرق قوات غير
عسكريه تابعه لها مغامره روسيا بارسال
قوات غير عسكريه متضمنا متطوعين وتجنيد
سجناء بعد قرار بوتين باعاده تعبئه جيشه
تفتح باب مخاوف بارتكاب مجازر وتجنيد
ميليشيات وخلق مزيدا من الفوضى لتتحول الى
حرب غير نظاميه وفقا محللين غربيين فبحسب
صحيفه الامريكيه اضاف الكرملين
318,000 جندي الى الجيش الروسي منهم حوالي
49,000 في القتال بالفعل
الخسائر الروسيه فادحه وواضحه على الارض
رغم قصفهم المتواصل الدليل على ذلك هو
مقتل مجندين روس في غضون ايام من نقلهم
الى شرقي اوكرانيا ويرجع ذلك لتلقيهم قدرا
ضئيلا من التدريب او عدم تلقي اي تدريب
على الاطلاق مع وجود نقص في المعدات حتى
وان القوات الروسيه تقوم باجراء تدريبات
في بلاروسيا بسبب العجز في اطقم التدريب
والذخيره والمنشات في روسيا وفق وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه
هذا واكد مراقبون وجود اختفاء روسي الى حد
ما في مدينه خرسون جنوبيه اوكرانيا حيث
انسحبت بعض الوحدات العسكريه بينما تستمر
بارسال قواتها الى منطقه دون باس لوقف
التقدم الاوكراني هناك بينما زالت تحاول
قوت اوكرانيا استعاده مدنها والاقتراب
ببطء من مدينه خرسون التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا رشا خياطه العربيه